talks about the blood of americaas being
poisoned echoing the same exact
language used the Nazi
Germany he proudly post on social media
the words that best describe his 2024
campaign quote
Revenge quote power and quote
dictatorship there's no confusion about
who Trump is what he intends to do there
it is Mr Mr unifier in Chief's official
ramp up to comparing his predecessor to
Hitler in the very same speech he
pretended like he was the only guy
around who could save
America
today I make this sacred pledge to you
the defense protection and
preservation of American democracy will
remain as it has been the central cause
of my
presidency he wants you to think that
the next 11 months are not about getting
America back on track where she should
be where people aren't living paycheck
to paycheck where our borders aren't
being overrun where people aren't scared
to walk down the street no he wants you
to think it's all about what he calls
democracy where the democracy is still
America's sacred cause is the most
urgent question of our time and that's
what the 2024 election is all about is
it because just after Biden stood there
in front of multiple American flags
calling Trump the greatest threat to our
democracy we learn the Supreme Court of
the United States is hearing a case
about Democrats trying to take that very
thing away trying to take Donald Trump
off the ballot joining us now is Steven
Miller former senior adviser to
president Trump and the founder of
America First legal and Kurt schlicker
retired US army colonel and Senior
columnist at Town hall.com gentlemen
thanks for being with us tonight Stephen
thank you it's a pretty fearful message
that Joe Biden angrily related to the
the American public about the threat
represented by Donald Trump the threat
to democracy will be will Americans in
your estimation be afraid they are about
to lose their
democracy I think the clear purpose of
Biden's message is twofold first
obviously is to try to terrify Suburban
voters ahead of the elections and that
will be tremendously unsuccessful as we
see in the polling but the second and
even more nefarious objective is trying
to create the pretext the predicate for
a vast police and surveillance state so
what you see is the enormous tools of
the disposal of the Department of
Justice the enormous tools of the
disposal of the Department of Homeland
Security being AR raid for the purpose
of trying to crush political descent in
America censoring Free Speech putting
political dissidents in jail for
outrageous sentences you see for example
pro-life Americans being raided being
threatened with enormous jail time for
nonviolent activities nonviolent
protests while political allies of the
democratic party like BLM are allowed to
Riot with impunity allowed to attack and
assault with impunity the message is
clear if you are seen as An Enemy of the
State you will be persecuted and if
you're the leader of the opposition
Donald Trump you will be taken off the
ballot and you will be thrown in jail
but if you an ally of the ruling party
then you will be shielded no matter how
great your crimes and that includes by
the way the crime of having completely
open borders every single day in this
country that's true no sense of
self-awareness or irony it would seem
Curt here is what Joe says Trump's
campaign is about watch Donald Trump's
campaign is about him not America not
you Donald Trump's campaign is obsessed
with the past not the future he's
willing to sacrifice our democracy put
himself in
power our campaign is different for me
and KLA our campaign is about America
it's about you it's about every age and
background that occupi this country
again Kurt no sense of self-awareness or
irony as he spent the entire speech
looking backwards and at one point
called the Oval Office my Oval
Office well well well first of all I
have to say that I'm really glad that
the asthma that kept uh Joe Biden from
defending his country in uniform when it
called on him isn't keeping him from
protecting democracy Now from half of
Americans who actually want to vote for
the candidate their choice uh as Stephen
pointed out he is censoring free speech
he is arresting political opponents he's
waging unrestricted lawfare upon them uh
it is a disgrace and it's not going to
work because you know I was just out
driving around today gas is like four or
five bucks a gallon you go into the
grocery store you come out wearing one
of those little barrels with no close
you've got no money left America is
falling apart we are we our our foreign
policy is a disgrace we're getting
pushed around by the Chinese by the
Iranians by whoever the hell the houthis
are we got run out of uh Afghanistan
with 13 people dead it's a disgrace and
he can't hide it by lying against half
of Americans you know will the people
he's lying about right now the people
who support Donald Trump they built this
country they feed this country they fuel
this country and they defend this
country again unlike Joe Biden I don't
want to hear one damn word from the
scile corrupt creep Kurt you know you're
an attorney uh we let off tonight as
well with the news that the Supreme
Court will hear the case in the attempt
to remove him from the primary ballot in
Colorado I put nothing past the Supreme
Court I don't put much faith in the
decisions or our ability to predict the
decisions of the Supreme Court again as
an attorney how do you expect that case
to go before The Supreme Court
will when you ask me about the laware
being waged about uh against Donald
Trump as an attorney that presumes this
is some sort of legal Endeavor as a
legal matter the criminal indictments
and this ridiculous attempt to keep half
of Americans from being able to vote for
who they choose I it's a joke that it's
going to get tossed out by the Supreme
Court the question is whether soda mayor
and uh whether Joe Biden's appointee
will actually vote and make at 90 and
totally repudiate this disgusting
dictatorship action
it's we're going to win it's a matter of
whether we preserve the premises that
make America what it is in the process
you know Stephen you brought up the
substance that represents a threat to
democracy the attack on Free Speech I
thought Jonathan Turley today after Joe
Biden's speech put it very succinctly
when it comes to who's the biggest
threat to the pillars of our democracy
watch when he talks about the freedom of
speech the Biden Administration I've
written before is the most anti-free
speech Administration since the
administration of John Adams I mean his
administration has carried out what a
federal court called an
orwellian uh censorship program with the
help of social media companies so toally
agrees with you Stephen on what
represents a threat to our democracy
what I'd love to ask you though Stephen
is there seems to be a change they would
have us believe that Joe Biden would
like to run against Trump that he
actually has a chance to beat Donald
Trump but listening to Joe Biden today
he's already taking on Trump that would
seem to empower trump it would seem to
either suggest a he knows it's
inevitable that his opponent will be
Donald Trump or he's seen the polling
and now he knows oh I don't know that I
do want to run run against Donald Trump
so I need to start attacking
Trump well first of all they've seen the
same polling that all of us have seen in
the swing state showing historic leads
for president Trump but secondly the
prosecutions themselves are the proof of
the point their election strategy is
literally to put president Trump in jail
that is their actual election strategy
with multiple criminal persecutions and
this is another very important point I
want to make who is the audience for
that speech is it the American people
yes but it's somebody else too it's Jack
Smith it's the Department of Justice it
is the judges in each of these cases by
saying that his opponents are Nazis his
message is they must be destroyed it is
dangerous rhetoric it strikes at the
very heart of America's whole system of
laws and Justice and it signals that
there's no end to which they will not go
to maintain their control over power in
this country really good stuff Kurt
Stephen thank you both so much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else